hey there welcome to Oz trailer
commentaries show her we watch the
honest trailer and commentate about it
yes very simple show you know you're in
for if you stick around to the end you
will see cut jokes and things that
didn't make it into the final version
yeah that's damn Earl yeah it's like
tuning in to your favorite sitcom and
then seeing the things that weren't good
enough to make it on the air only the
best for the fans today we're talking
about the film get out yeah
which what what's left for there to say
about get out that we could add to the
discussion we didn't do it because we
thought it would be too hard yes and we
didn't know what we would say about it
but you voted you voted and we listened
yeah so we did our best
yep I don't know yeah you get you get
three Joe's not here today but three
straight white guys take on get out
the ideal group yes I give the final
word who should be taking apart this one
but I can't say that I I don't want to
say I was lukewarm on the movie the
first time I saw it but I was like it
had been built up so much the
expectations were so high going in that
when I walked out it's like gasps good
horror movie yeah second time through
second third time you get a lot more out
of it is one that got better on the
rewatch I was much the same way I liked
the movie a lot on the first watch but
you know everyone else was like so up
here and I was like is there something
wrong with me cuz I merely liked it but
the second time I'm like oh wow this is
really well put together in such an
intricate subtle way that it kind of
goes beyond the broader themes that hit
you the first time you see it and you
you were I was able to appreciate it
much more cinematically yes details yeah
Kubrick ian is a word that doesn't get
used lightly but I think is deserved
here yeah because everything seemed
really really well-thought-out and very
deliberate yeah and so so we did it we
made it the most profitable film of the
year we solved racism we've made get out
and now it's over and we can all pet
ourselves on the back we as a society
that Spencer and I
specifically exactly yeah problem solved
this is all we needed problem solved I
raised my tea to you yeah it was
actually a really smart way to handle
the topic of like this this allegorical
horror of not being in control of your
own body and I can't wait to see what
Jordan Peele does next because
apparently these are the types of movies
he wants to make good yeah I would love
for him to make 10 more these kinds of
movies yeah
not 10 get out no but like 10 more of
these kind of like kind of genre ask
deeper it's kind of what they were doing
with comedy and key and Peele which is
like key and Peele was such a kind of
broadly a sketch show it's like oh it's
a sketch show but then like inside so
many of the sketches or these kind of
like smaller statements about things and
I like that he kind of took that
mentality of like I'm gonna take as onra
and then inside of that I'm gonna put in
these things that are deeper than the
outside you know may-maybe tray it was a
exactly and I hope that he is successful
moving forward in whatever he does so
that we don't get get out - yeah I don't
think we need to get out again
get back out get back out get in get in
yeah what do we get in tell us in the
comments below with the sequel to get
out be get in or get get to out get out
again
get out again get out again I don't know
clearly we don't that much same with
this so let's just watch the headphones
hopefully the lights don't go out while
we're watching the trailer yeah the
following trailer is rated s for spoiler
issues though if we died there yes you
have to vote for the 2017 movies you
wanted us to make an honest trailer for
here's your number two choice
it was too hard once right there l
didn't get up forget serial killers
demons and evil clowns because a more
terrifying inescapable unstoppable force
is coming to get you rich white people
get out
I mean someone run the numbers I'm
statistically more likely to die at the
hands or indirectly from a rich white
person than I am from a serial killer
I think that's gotta be first human
statistically definitely a demon I don't
know how many contracted demon related
deaths are on the book I don't know
about clowns because I think that you
have to murder somebody to earn your
face paint as yeah when you graduate
from clown school you have to it's like
getting your double-oh-seven you have to
kill somebody and then you're it's this
the the it's the nose ceremony the
ritual of the nose yeah no I think
statistically it is probably more likely
that I'm gonna get hit by a Mercedes and
then then a demon that's gonna take a
killer or yeah exactly yeah and I think
that's the best horrors it is it makes
you look at something that seems so
common in a new way and seem like like
it's more threatening than then you
realized it except if you're making the
happening because then it just makes
trees hilarious hilarious I didn't know
you can make botany funny but damn it if
didn't like Shamu I didn't find a way
anyway you like hot dogs
yeah let's keep going catch the film
that proved once again that diversity
quality and making but loads of money
aren't mutually exclusive
that was the most profitable fun
atmosphere only because everyone bought
a ticket but because it was so low
budget they had to plug the Windows
Phone wait they make Windows Phones and
it's gone Christmas movie yeah fun of
the phone conversation literally looking
at the background for details - oh cool
black I didn't notice this he's very
good at kind of like the deflection of
like I'm just gonna let that slide
yep he's so polite he'll stick around
his girlfriend's creepy murder house
even when people are literally screaming
get out in his face it's not a big deal
forget about it it is a big deal yeah I
just spent the weekend for example at my
girlfriend's family's house and if I
were outside in the yard and someone
whom I did not really know came up to me
and yelled after you took a photo of
them after take a photo of them yelled
get out in my face I've okay yeah
exactly I might say look I think you
should stay at the Hyatt see if there's
an Airbnb me yeah is there something
yeah I mean that's true of most that's
the horror movies like oh [ __ ] once one
person's dead like your door
disappearing or sword something really
weird happens like a normal human would
would move or leave leave the camp leave
the camp leave the camp move away from
well I guess you can't really move away
from Freddy Krueger but yeah they tried
yeah we're in a horror movie so people
just shrug that kind of thing off
but it's that convention again of just
like he this movie worked because he was
able to use that horror convention of
like something's wrong but I'm going to
stay inside of this bigger story which
is kind of what made the movie work yeah
yeah yeah let's keep going not a big
deal it's not a big deal
forget about it luckily there's rod one
of the best movie friends of all time
watch is the kind of guy who yells at
the screen during a horror movie she is
like a mother it's a chance cause like
actually being in what's the favorite
thing you've ever heard yelled at a
screen during a movie oh wow that's uh
not yelled at the screen there was there
was an old couple behind me why he said
that movie open water open its the
divers that get that get like strangers
in the surface and they're in the middle
of the ocean and the sharks surrounding
them I remember seeing that one in the
theater there was an old couple behind
me and it's like a very quiet very tense
part of the movie and I heard it was old
people whispering which is essentially
speaking voice I heard
I think jaws is better like that's the
standard yeah mine was also during a
water-based horror movie Lake Placid oh
yeah where Oliver Platt is in the
titular lake and he is he's looking left
and right for for the monster and it
rises up behind him and one gentleman
behind me said hey that thing looks like
it's gonna eat all of her play and then
the guy who was there with him goes at
the top of his lungs to the whole screen
eat Oliver play wow they really lighten
the mood yeah otherwise tense moment of
Lake Placid yeah I'm generally not
amused dip it's on the movie I think
horror and comedy you know horror movies
I'm okay with our movies just fine
because that's part of it it's a
communal experience especially if it
like if it's a great horror movie people
generally don't do that but if it's
terrible and like the bye-bye man like I
don't mind your [ __ ]
yeah but I would argue even good horror
movies get you if not to actually yell
to feel like don't go in there don't do
it yeah so yeah yeah anyways I love rod
yes keep going she is like a mother it's
a chance to shine by actually being
inside the horror movie
I mean I've told you not to go in the
house thank God for rod because the
alternate ending is super realistic
super depressing same difference
no the alternate ending is at the end
rod it is not rod it is the police and
he essentially is they they win because
they frame him for their murders
basically and he's in jail which seemed
like the where I thought it was going it
made it like so such a victorious moment
because you thought this was a movie
that was like it had something to say so
of course it would blame him for
everything that happened he would go
into the prison system and I think I
remember reading Jordan peels like times
are depressing enough right now that I
wanted to not pile on and like give
people a lift at the end of this movie
well I think that's again he
that's one of those this movie works
well is he knew when to kind of step on
the gas and when to pump the brakes and
I it worked for me as a viewer like I
was expecting the same thing I was kind
of bracing for it I'm like oh man this
is gonna suck
he's gonna he's gonna go down for this
like oh and then it was rot I was like
yes hell yes so I was yes it was good
Jordan Peele smartly knew he knew what
we would be thinking yes yeah and he
gave us he let us let us off the hook
which is nice of him thank you George
banks off the hook let's keep going
aim difference enjoy deliciously cruel
casting that makes villains out of white
people's favorite white people even
ridiculous despair West Wing alums and
girls girls into a broad caricatures of
society's worst impressions of them and
if that makes you upset now you have
some inkling of how black people feel
when they watch almost every other
horror movie brothers don't last long as
situations like this seriously buy
people's main roles in horror is to
either die first or comment on how often
they die first the black guy always dies
first pause there's actually in some
doing some research for this that is a
that is a pop culture misconception is
it yeah some reason that narrative is is
popularized in movies but it's
statistically not necessarily the case
okay it's it's weird I don't know why
it's one of those weird things that laid
such a meme of like the black guy dies
first
yeah exactly it's it's very I don't know
no one knows no ice cream to wisdom
I remember screamed to was the first one
was the cameraman is like I'm getting
out of here yeah okay well I mean scream
to knows about horror movie so I just I
took scream two's word for it but scream
2 lied to me as it lied to everyone all
of us going into the movie who thought
it would be Wow anywhere near as good as
the first one okay well yeah maybe we
need to modify that a that that
conception and just be like the black
guy probably won't live through the
horror movie that that is often true
yeah that is often true yeah the final
girl is not usually a black guy
that is true unless it's that as I'm
living now you're living dead yeah
there's a dog a dead
I know lies living dead okay anyways I
had clearly I'm a horror expert he was
the final girl in that movie wasn't he
yeah however they did that Jordan Peele
Jordan go let's go back to night of
Living Dead that was that that was a
downer oh yeah Night of the Living Dead
that was that was a night of Jordan
Peele ending that was a there's no well
again someone's gonna be like yeah but I
don't think there's any zombie movies
with happier next yeah well I mean the
earth dies and all of them yes really no
any kind of happy ending is really a
real micro view of a macro problem I'll
be moving yeah someone make that one
yeah let's go revisit all the little
details you didn't see the first time
like Rose stands up to the cops just so
they don't leave a paper trail you don't
have to give him your ideas you ever
done anything wrong the old people drive
by cars to symbolize how they're also
driving black bodies and he's running to
the bigs to cover up the scars from
their surgery but then try to ignore
little details that don't add up like
brains ages fast his body's so a
transplant wouldn't add them in years no
one ever notices all these guys went
missing after dating the same girl and
why does she live separate from the milk
it's not I think why people do is it is
it is it no I've never done that never
no never set well is that the blood
thirst of white people dry cereal I've
had dry cereal yeah I've had a glass of
milk in my life yeah but I've never had
cereal and milk next to each other and
not mix the two
yeah that's insane I've never had milk
in the proximity of cereal and not mix
them together in a weird way though it
like seems like a fake thing white
people would do like yes so white you
eat your your Froot Loops next year like
a Def Jam comic would definitely make
fun of a white person for that it does
seem like it's a very white person thing
to do yeah maybe I should start doing it
I don't know yeah it was very effective
well yeah it's so off kilter it puts me
off or immediately exactly what do you
stop that stop to put to put the milk in
to put the milk in the seeds yes it's
very effective because it
I wanted to not I wanted to get out of
that house yeah she was I think the my
favorite performance in that movie yeah
she was great looking back over it when
you see everything she does has like a
second meaning now that you know just
even the part with the purse you know I
can't find the keys she's like oh oh
anyways that was know she talked she's
still alive for for get is she I think
she saw if they leave it can open it I
think she'd but I think she bit the dust
well depends on the sequel let's get out
again but it live separate from the milk
it's not I think why people do is it is
it so gather round for a film that flips
your preconceived notions on its head
that progressives can be racist to the
TSA can be useful once in a while I'm TS
okay and getting into an interracial
relationship it's a huge mistake because
you can't trust these white girls sorry
and listen a lot of lemonade damn
Becky's are everywhere the old man on
the staff and I had to trust Joe and
Spencer on that one k Yonsei I mean I
know usual album known as lemonade I
know there was reference to a certain
Becky with the good hair but the good
hair used to describe white women that's
what I didn't know also oral sex but
that's a whole different story
oh the Becky with the good hair is
whoever jay-z cheated on see that I knew
I did not know I did not know that my
cultural awareness stopped at that point
and I did not realize that Becky had
gone on to to refer to a trifling white
white lady as eyes are dreadful exactly
as I later found out so that shows you
how plugged into to pop culture
generally other than movies I am oh
hello because I there's no need to learn
anything other than movies so yeah I
envy you I'm very plugged in you know
it's I can tell you about you know where
the hoverboard is
you know fidget spin I don't know what
to dab dab in you've never dab never
dabbed either kind of DAB I didn't I
wish I still didn't know who Logan Paul
was but Society took care of that one
for me so yeah I am horribly horribly at
a step he's secured and pure America
let's keep them keep them in amber
lemonade damn Becky's are everywhere
starring Everybody Hates Chris always
bring black up the lost Kardashian Ben
Carson I got that one nikita or stir
some tea sometimes your words just
hypnotize me thanks challenge one timing
mumford son and an evocative symbol of
the marginalization of black people in
america i mean black hole son this i
knew the 70s movie i'm just glad this
movie did well so i finally know whose
key and whose Peele
i swear it's not a race thing the show
was just key and Peele
they never said which one was which
seriously I'm not a racist in fact I
would have voted for Obama a third time
it but I wouldn't voted for Obama for a
third term if I could oh no this is
great didn't John find out he was a
furry during Zootopia yeah not the
actual John the character he's like got
a dull marriage in Fifty Shades of Grey
yeah we kind of we put the epic voice
guy through his paces he this has been a
journey of self-discovery his child
tutored him on the meanings of Superman
the Superman mythos yeah yeah someone
should probably try to go back and like
track the character of epic voice guy
because he's he's lonely very very sad
and lonely x-men and he still attached a
lot of childhood things yeah Ninja
Turtles yeah he's kind of taken on his
own character that is not the actual Jon
Malin John Bailey
no no epic voice guy Z no it's more a
reflection of us sadly yeah it's if
anything hmm yeah let's watch some
deleted scenes sure get out get
with those deleted scenes feast your
eyes on an all-you-can-eat buffet of
racism in all its insidious Ward's from
the overt not bad to the subtle so how
long has this been going on this thing -
the kind of well-meaning black is
infection to the systemic you know I
could give it what what car er I want
your I am an to the kind where you feel
guilty for always confusing which guy
was key and which guy was peel just like
that part of the show yeah Doronin swipe
left swipe left thirst trap serial
killer
bananas Republican that's the one that
got her butt licked on girls right yeah
Joe just said that out loud and we
thought it was so funny that it had to
be in there somewhere
yeah she isn't a famous girls episode of
about the the tossing of the salad yes
anyways good and also bananas Republican
we have I think what are the reason we
it was the the joke is about her clothes
yeah absolutely
Banana Republic like like a white
button-down in big khakis yes like a
banana republic outfit interpose but she
probably would not be Russia would be a
Democrat but we were afraid if we put
that in and people would think that we
were calling off the racists and the
movies Republicans which were not
because they were in fact at least today
and we're gonna get yelled at about this
one no matter well I know but I just
want to make sure that people that's why
we this is what the show is about it's
like we wanted to make sure that it was
a clothing joke and not a political you
know the joke behind the joke that
didn't even make it into the video
that's why you watch this [ __ ] why
you're here alright quality time keep
God licked on girls right
hypnotic Tea Party but that's all of my
business Kermit me maniac it's not brain
surgery Macaulay cokehead Conor McGregor
now you're in Wisconsin and the only
time anyone has ever been happy to see
airport security
okay you might be mad at this movie for
one reason or another but you'll never
be as mad as Sam Jackson that they
didn't cast him yes Sam Jackson was very
obsessed with a cat well more that they
cast a British person yes he said it was
an American story but I think reading
the subtext of that is they're very
upset they didn't cast Sam Jackson you
think he wanted to be like the lead role
I think he was really upset like this
would be a movie that he would really
want to be in and he'd be that's too old
he couldn't play Everest I guess he
couldn't play the groundskeepers either
all right fine well you're off the hook
this time
Sam Jackson Jackson he'll do anything
for a million dollars like I wouldn't
yeah he'll do ads for a million dollars
yeah what a sellout
I say give me a ten would say anything
say whatever you want I so would have
not done deep blue sea for four million
dollars yeah it's called integrity give
me a break I would've done deep blue sea
for $400 yeah you can take half of that
I would have paid $400 for a deep blue
sea a set visit yeah I'm gonna paid to
be in that movie I think people forget
about actors is uh generally they're
professionals like everyone else and you
know they can't all be Daniel day-lewis
just complan away not everyone wants to
cobble between films anyways unattached
picky Daniel day-lewis yeah is he
married I don't know who knows let's say
he even Daniel day-lewis there's that
been a role yeah we don't have anything
to say but get out to begin with yeah
this is a stretch but I hope we
entertained you in that video and in
this very one yeah and I hope you'll
return next week where we will be doing
one that we dislike that we should have
done last time that's not that's not a
clue
we get another one that we skipped but
not because we didn't have anything and
we hope that it's the last time we ever
have to do it I hope it is also the last
time we hope the last time was the last
time yeah this is hopefully the last
last yeah I'm so night night night night
and goodbye we'll see you next week yep
[Music]
you